من فضلك في كل مكان من فضلك
في فبراير، حُكم على
ضابط شرطة العاصمة السابق ديفيد كاريك بـ
36 حكمًا بالسجن مدى الحياة
لمدة 20 عامًا تقريبًا، وقد أصبح استغلال كاريك
لمنصبه في القوة لإكراه
ومهاجمة النساء اللاتي يحملن مسدسًا
سمة فريدة من نوعها لإساءته استخدامه لتهديد
ضحاياه.  كنت
عضوًا في قسم مسلح نادر من شرطة المملكة المتحدة
مكلف بالدفاع عن
المباني الحكومية رفيعة المستوى
والوزراء، ولا يزال يحيرني كيف
تمكن وحش من
ارتداء هذا الزي الرسمي الذي خدم فيه ناثان بوش
في نفس الوحدة بينما
كان كاريك هناك، هل هذا يجعلك  إن التفكير
بشكل مختلف في وقتك يجعلني
أتساءل على
الأرجح عن كل شخص أعمل
معه
بعد أن اعترف كاريك بالذنب في 71
جريمة جنسية اعترفت شرطة العاصمة بأن
كاريك قد لفت
انتباهها سابقًا والقوات الأخرى تسع مرات، لقد
أضعنا فرصًا مع مرور الوقت
للتعرف على هوية الشخص.  نمط السلوك المسيء
أمضت CNN أكثر من شهر في النظر
في تلك الفرص الضائعة،
ووجدت أنه في مناسبتين على الأقل
لم تتبع الشرطة
إجراءاتها الخاصة للتعامل مع سوء السلوك،
وبالتالي لم تفوت
عنف كاريك ولكنها فشلت في التعامل معه
بالخطورة التي كان عليها.  يستحق تركه حرًا
لمقابلة المزيد من الضحايا،
تحدثنا عبر رسالة نصية إلى إحدى هؤلاء
الضحايا دارسيان التي التقت كاريك في عام 2020
بعد أشهر من سوء المعاملة، وأبلغت عنه
إلى مركز شرطة خارج لندن في
يوليو 2021. ليس من السهل عليك
الوصول إلى حل  مركز الشرطة وأخبر
شرطيًا أنني تعرضت للاغتصاب على يد شرطي
تم وضع كاريك في مهام مقيدة
وتم إزالة بندقيته أثناء
التحقيق ولكن لم يتم إيقاف
دارسيون وانتهى الأمر بسحب
شكواها ولم أشعر بالحماية
وكلما ذهبت إلى مركز الشرطة
للإدلاء ببيان آخر طلبته
ولم يخبرني أحد بأي شيء، لذلك شعرت
بالصدمة الشديدة واعتقدت أنهم لم
يصدقوني في
غضون شهرين. كان كاريك يستعد
للعودة إلى واجباته الكاملة مسلحًا مرة
أخرى، وهو ما لم يكن يجب أن يحدث أبدًا
من خلال بحثنا الخاص في
بروتوكول ميتس للتعامل مع حالات سوء السلوك كان
ينبغي
التحقيق بشكل أكبر في ادعاءات دارسيون على الرغم من
سحبها للشكوى وكان
الضباط المكلفون بالقضية سيتمكنون من
الوصول إلى قاعدة بيانات قابلة للبحث والتي
سجلت حادثة سابقة واحدة على الأقل
كان فيها كاريك عنيفًا تجاه
امرأة.  قبل خمسة أشهر فقط من لقاء
دارسيون به في سبتمبر 2019،
أبلغ أحد الجيران أنهم رأوا
كاريك يمسك امرأة من رقبتها
أثناء حادث منزلي في
شرطة هيرتفوردشاير هناك، وأخبرونا أنهم
أرسلوا تقريرًا عن الجريمة إلى شرطة العاصمة
على وجه التحديد إلى القسم الذي يتعامل مع
الشكاوى ضد الضباط  تُعرف الآن باسم
مديرية المعايير المهنية أو
DPS الآن وفقًا لإرشادات DPS الخاصة،
وهو ادعاء خطير مثل
هذا كان ينبغي تصعيده
للإبلاغ عن العنف المنزلي من قبل طرف ثالث بشكل
واضح للغاية وقد تم ذلك في ضوء
أشخاص آخرين وحقيقة أنه في عام 2019
كان كاريك يحمل مسدسًا، لذا كان ينبغي
تصعيد الأمر نظرًا لوجود
علامة حمراء هناك ولكن لم يتم اتخاذ أي إجراء آخر،
ولم تكن الضحية ترغب في متابعة
الاتهامات في ذلك الوقت، لكن
شرطة هيرتفوردشاير أخبرت شبكة CNN أنه منذ
الحكم على كاريك، تقدموا الآن
بادعاءات  ضده،
أفهم أنك رهن الاعتقال في
أكتوبر 2021. تم القبض على كاريك أخيرًا
مرة أخرى عندما تقدمت امرأة أخرى
بادعاء الاغتصاب بعد ثلاثة
أشهر من شكوى دارسيان، وتم
توجيه التهم إليه وأعيد فتح قضية دارسيون
وأخبرت الله ونفسي،
أشكرك يا رب على العرض.  ضحية أخرى،
لذا صدقوني الآن أنها ليست وحدها
في هذه التجربة من بين 573
ضابط شرطة قابلتهم متهمين بارتكاب جرائم جنسية من قبل
الجمهور على مدار 11 عامًا، تم اتهام اثنين فقط مما
يزيد من الرعب،
وأكدت الأمور أنه
تم وضع اثنين من زملاء كاريك في السجن  في
واجبات مقيدة بعد الاتصال بإحدى
ضحاياه، ذكرت سكاي نيوز أنهم
كانوا يرسلون لها رسائل موحية جنسيًا
حتى الآن ولم يواجه أي ضابط شرطة أي
عواقب لفشله في إيقاف كاريك
لسنوات عديدة، وقد
أعادت هيئة مراقبة الشرطة في المملكة المتحدة الآن فتح مراجعة في
التعامل مع قضية كاريك على الرغم من
قولهم سابقًا إنه ليس لديهم سبب للتحقيق، ولا تزال
القوة تكافح
لإثبات قدرتها على الحفاظ على سلامة النساء
ومحاسبة ضباطها،
وتواصلت CNN مع شرطة العاصمة لإجراء
هذا التحقيق وأحالونا
إلى تصريحاتهم الحالية  بخصوص كاريك،
قالوا إنهم لن يعلقوا
أكثر بينما هناك
مراجعات حكومية مستمرة للتعامل مع
قضيته، ومنذ الحكم على كاريك،
تقدم المزيد من الضحايا المحتملين
إلى الشرطة، وفي الوقت نفسه،
أخبر مركز عدالة المرأة شبكة CNN أن بعض
ضحايا كاريك يفكرون الآن في الأمر.
دعوى قضائية جماعية ضد
شرطة العاصمة حتى الآن لم يواجه أي ضابط شرطة
أي عواقب لفشله في
إيقاف كاريك كاتي، بوغليز سي إن إن لندن